La volta al món a peu, dia 251.
Avui comença la meva travessa a peu per Centràsia.
Després d'haver caminat des de Barcelona fins a Tbilisi,
fa una setmana vaig agafar un avió fins aquí, fins a Uzbekistan,
on he estat els últims 6-7 dies fent turisme,
turisme amb tren i amb taxi, i avui començo a caminar.
L'objectiu és molt clar, arribar a la frontera més alta del món
abans de camanxar en pil hivern.
Des d'aquí, des de Samarkand, la llegendària Samarkand,
caminaré només 37 quilòmetres fins a la frontera amb Tajikistan.
Després cauré tot el país de Tajikistan,
per totes les muntanyes del Pamir,
fins a una de les fronteres més inhòspites del món,
la frontera amb Tajikistan i Xina.
Després faré un petit tram de la Xina fins a la frontera més alta del món,
la frontera entre Xina i Pakistan,
i baixaré per la carretera del Karakorum fins a Islamabad, Inshallah.
Nervis? Bastants.
Avui és dia, divendres, 7 d'agost,
i podria ser el dia més calorós de tota la volta al món a peu.
Aquesta d'aquí, darrere meu, serà la carretera, no em complicaré,
que seguiré 37 quilòmetres fins a la frontera,
i, doncs això, és molt calorós aquí a Uzbekistan,
avui hi haurà 30 i pico graus llargs.
Per sort, pel que he vist, hi ha alguns bars, alguns supermercats,
entre més, llavors, bueno, en cas d'haver de parar,
doncs podré fer-ho per refrescar.
I, doncs, anem a caminar, i us explico més coses.
Són les 10 i 10, fa uns 20 minuts de camí,
i he començat una mica tard,
perquè pel matí he hagut d'anar a Correus,
que no obria fins a les 9,
a enviar algunes altres postals
de gent que s'havia apuntat a última hora,
i també alguns impagats,
que han pagat el mes d'agost, també, a última hora.
Bueno, crec que serà tot el dia així,
carretera, amb cotxes,
i soroll, espero que se m'escolti bé,
amb la cancel·lació de soroll del micròfon,
i reto, clar,
podria evitar, aleshores, de més calor,
però no tinc més remei.
Samarkand és menys calorós que Bukhara,
perquè estem a uns 700 metres sobre el nivell del mar,
Bukhara està a 100 metres, o així.
Aquesta diferència de nivell aporta un pèl més de fresqueta,
però fa molta calor.
Vaig amb pantalons llargs, com podeu veure.
He pensat, prova-ho, perquè així t'hauràs de posar
menys crema de sol.
I aquests pantalons són molt fresquets i tal.
A veure, clar, passa menys aire,
tinc més calor als peus, a les cames.
Però no és dramàtica, llavors, de moment, m'ho quedo.
Ni Uzbekistan, ni els tres propers països,
Tajikistan, China i Pakistan,
tenen Google Street View,
cosa que dificulta les coses.
Llavors, ja no sabia com seria aquesta carretera,
però, com podeu veure,
hi ha una zona per vianants,
que està molt bé,
per la qual puc caminar,
i, de tant en quant, hi ha arbres,
cosa que em proporciona bastanta ombra.
Recorrem que el clima aquí es muy, muy, muy, muy sec,
por tanto, la ombra, bueno,
podría decir que se está bien, entre comillas, salón.
Vale, una cosa muy interesante
que descubrí ayer,
y que si hubiera sabido,
habría cambiado mi visión, tanto de Bukhara
como de Samarkand.
Que es que aquí, la mayoría,
la inmensa mayoría de la población
es tajika.
La mayoría de la población de Samarkand
y Bukhara no son uzbeks,
sino que son culturalmente
culturalmente, étnicamente,
podríamos decir, tajiks,
tienen la nacionalidad uzbeka,
hablan uzbek también, pero entre ellos
hablan tajik,
tajik de Tajikistán.
Son idiomas completamente diferentes.
El tajik es una variante
del persa, del farsi,
del idioma que hablan en Irán,
¿de acuerdo? Es un país que, bueno,
son amigos en Irán,
un país de agricultores, de pastores,
de gente que vive en la montaña, y tal.
En cambio, el uzbek es un país
turquí.
El idioma uzbek
tiene relación con el idioma turc,
y tradicionalmente habían sido tribus
más nómadas, ¿no?
Los tajiks siempre han vivido aquí,
y los uzbeks han venido con una migración
desde el norte, a Turquía, tal,
pero sí, sí, ven de aquí.
Pero bueno, por lo que he leído,
se ve que hay normalidad,
se portan bien, son amigos,
hablan el uzbek, como he dicho,
y, bueno, comparten todo,
y no pasa nada. De hecho, hay matrimonios
normalizados entre tajiks y uzbeks,
pero sí, sí. Samarkand y Bukhara
hablan este idioma,
y ¿por qué Bukhara y Samarkand
no son parte de Tajikistan, no?
Pues bueno, eso es culpa de los rusos,
que cuando se van a accionar
estos dos países a la Unión Soviética,
pues decidieron partir
a Uzbekistán de esta manera,
y ya está.
Y ya está. Les iba a ser igual
si aquí vivían tajiks o uzbeks, pero ya está.
Van a hacer que la República
de Tajikistán esté delimitada
por las montañas y a Uzbekistán
por el deserto. Sí, se acabó.
Las doce y diez.
Veig muntanyes allà al fons.
No és Tajikistán encara,
són muntanyes d'Uzbekistán.
Les de Tajikistán, bueno,
hi ha una mica de núvols, ombra,
vull dir, boira, no sé si...
Encara no es veuen. Bueno, com són les dotze,
les últimes quatre hores són les de més intensitat de calor,
però he de dir que fins ara,
les dos hores i escaig que he caminat,
bé, bastant bé, bastant bé.
Zones d'ombra, zones de sol,
però he pogut caminar.
La meva intenció no és parar
aquestes quatre hores a un lloc y ya está, simplemente,
continuaré, sí que pararé para ordenar
y ya está.
He parado para ordenar.
Me he de gastar todos, o los máximos
que pueda somos, que es la moneda
de Uzbekistán, antes de salir del país,
porque se ve que en Tajikistán es bastante difícil
cambiar de moneda, cosa sorprendente.
Porque son dos países que tienen mucha comunicación
y las fronteras están muy abiertas y tal, pero bueno.
Entonces he venido aquí,
a un restaurante, y el menú,
bueno, para comenzar el menú, no sé en qué idioma estaba,
si en ruso o en tajik, porque
tienen el mismo alfabeto, en cualquier caso,
como hay poca cobertura, no me lo traduce el traductor.
Entonces, he tenido que hablar con el cambrer
y le he hecho sonidos de animales, ¿no?
¿Esto qué es? ¿Be? ¿Mu?
Nos hemos entendido. Y había una cosa que tenía buena pinta,
que era una sopa que parecía fría,
es esto, pero en cualquier caso, yo lo he pedido, bueno,
el menú salía como en un bol.
Y me lo han portado en una jarra de cerveza.
Voy a probarla.
¡Qué bo!
¡Qué bo! No sabría decir...
Una sopa fría,
sabor una mica a yogur y hierbas.
¡Mol bo!
Y el agua en gas, ¿eh?
El agua en gas, creo que aquel tramo
de Georgia que hice
sin ver refrescos,
me ha ayudado a desengancharme una mica.
Bye bye!
Rachmat!
Muchos simpáticos estos,
se han puesto una foto con mi.
No sé qué diuen. Me ha costado... Espera, que activo el track, eh?
Me ha costado una hora y escacho
y me ha costado 75.000 només.
Y només porque
me quedan para gastar 105.000.
75.000 son unos 6 euros y
105.000 son unos
9 euros, bueno,
para sopar esta noche y almorzar algo al
mañana, básicamente. Es que cuesta gastarse aquí los
dineros, ¿eh? Es muy barato, especialmente
cuando surges de la zona turística.
Bueno, tú, pues sigue caminando,
que aún queda.
Ok!
D택 er
E
o
u
It's 7 and 7 in the afternoon, we're very close to the border, there's a lot of traffic.
It's a very busy day, in the morning too, but especially in the afternoon I'm eating an apple, that can't be good.
I feel my skin, I touch it like that and I feel it, I feel the dirt, dirt, dirt, very, very fine.
Well, now I'm in a place that has too many single-family houses around, all of them are houses, in fact, and of course I can't camp here.
I don't want to be seen, there are a lot of children, a lot of adolescents who don't have to do anything, but hey, they can come to see what's there and such.
Then I'll go out into the city about two kilometers and look for a place to camp.
I'm not going very well on time because the sun goes out at 7.30 more or less, but hey, something of light will stay.
I have provisioned myself with water, I have bought my own gun and I have already had dinner, so I don't have to do anything anymore, let's go.
It's 7.35, this would be the detour that I want to take to find a place to camp.
And we see that there is a field here and in this field there are cows, which I don't like.
I also see a kind of power station, but hey, it's not a house.
Cows are sometimes tied to the ground and can't move, I think these are free-range.
Let's see, cows in theory do nothing, if not, all of a sudden they turn into cows, as happened to me in Switzerland, which I have already told you several times.
Well, it seems that they are tied, good news.
Now I just have to find a flat place, which is not easy because I see that all the terrain has small mountains, because I guess that's the way they have to line up in Vladamor.
Well, I think that here it would not be a great place either, it is not completely flat, but hey, with the inflatable mat it is fixed.
I also see some cars there, I see what is a kind of house, I don't know if it's a house or I don't know what it is.
I listen to some machine working far away, but you listen, there is not much more option.
I stand and make a summary.
Today I want to do something that I know you can do and I have not done it with this tent yet.
Which is to take part of the outside tent, because of course, as it is hot, so that it passes a little in the air, because otherwise it is very claustrophobic.
Then it is done like this, it is done like this, the clips of the inside tent are removed, and let's see if it can be done, and these clips can be taken by the poles.
Like this, okay.
Then, well, look, now like this.
And well, without having to remove the whole tent from the top, which is a stick, having to remove everything, at least here, I think it will pass a lot of air, right?
What do you say?
Today I do not dry myself to make the summary, because the ground ... I will get wet, I will get wet my pants.
Then we do it like this.
37 kilometers today.
Look, I put on the lights of a car.
I hope he doesn't see me.
And nothing.
A soda.
Now I was doing days that I was not doing a summary, huh?
I'm forgetting.
No coffee.
I had ordered a tea for lunch.
So, a tea.
I have talked, like, with ... damn, today, maybe with five or six people.
Many very short conversations, huh?
They stopped me.
Hello, how are you?
Where are you from?
That's it.
Boom.
They didn't want to know either.
Okay, bye, bye.
Bye, that's it.
Nice, huh?
But, that's it.
And, uh, of money spent, well, you have seen it, I don't know, when it was this.
About 12 euros.
I put oil.
A little less.
I'm thirsty.
And I just bought water with gas.
Okay.
Tomorrow, big day, huh?
Tomorrow, big day, I cross the border with Tajikistan.
Let's see how it goes.
Good night.